hey Caitlyn yeah you know something cool
about our podcast what since like we're
never gonna break up or anything and
we're married and we're like a team yeah
I can keep on making this podcast
forever until we die and on like until
we die all right guys we have an
exciting podcast lined up for you guys
we are gonna be talking with our friend
Paul Jackman this is actually still from
our round of interviews that we did at
workbench con we've been we've been
spreading them out yeah you know we
really made that time count we're also
going to be talking about how we come up
with ideas and and kind of the the
process we go through before we even
start filming or editing or anything
like that I know if we have time we'll
play a little bit of would you rather
yeah I think we can fit it all in do all
the things that such are true philosophy
well first like if you guys haven't
heard of Paul Jacqueline he's just an
amazing YouTube creator his channel is
called Jackman works yeah I always like
Paul Jackson and then his thing and then
it doesn't come up and I'm like what oh
yeah Jacqueline works so on we first met
I had New York makerfaire mm-hmm and I
forget like who texted who first but
like we made plans to meet up okay
remembering events and everything yeah
first off should we talk about his
channel yeah oh yeah yeah so he's like a
woodworker he has a lot of really
awesome subtle humor in his videos very
dry but also it's like lots of magical
things happen right yes it's yeah
editing magic like yeah if you want to
get some fun ideas or figure out how to
remove 30 clamps just by jumping on a
pallet you watch Paul Jackman's video
does it via magic and I think it's a lot
of like you know
editing tricks and After Effects and
everything like that but like here's
another creative that puts a lot of time
into his edit to make them like next
level and like you don't want to look
away yeah you know like when you're
watching his videos if you if you blink
you might miss something cuz there's I
mean some things are very obvious and
some things are super subtle yeah yeah
so okay so go back to the story of
having that okay so at New York Maker
Faire that was our very first maker
event since starting our channel and we
kind of run into a few people we knew
some people were going we had chatted
with Paul like on Instagram or in
comments before the Jeff battle started
though I think before I think before
yeah um so we we had chatted a little
bit but we hadn't met and we were with a
group coordinating dinner and we didn't
have a car
Paul Jackman had a car somebody
coordinated with Paul ER we texted Paul
and he was like okay I'll pick you guys
up so we're on some random Street in
Queens we have no idea where we are we
were just and at the place where we were
supposed to meet and we see his bright
red Honda Fit like speeding by we're
like run into the street and hop into
his car yeah the first time we met like
oh hi we're just jumping into your car
okay I actually have like a clip of that
oh we did it was really bad because we
had the GoPro on your backpack and we
were running into this movie a really
old vlog we had a Maker Faire New York
vlog linked to it yeah I was back in the
day we met and we did start doing epic
jiff battles but that's not even there
like my favorite part of that story so
we we jumped into his car we went to
their Airbnb and we hung out oh no no we
we went to dinner and hung out with a
lot of fun people there but I think that
at some point before after dinner I
think after dinner
we just all decided to go to like a
supermarket or something yeah went to
the grocery the grocery store looks like
a long walk like a long sketchy streets
and it was just like such an adventure
it was like so random
and it just felt like we were back in
college or something yes like random
adventures here we go yeah but uh I
think that uh one of the things that we
talked about in the interview coming up
is how some of the the recent builds he
was done has been like gigantic and if
you guys haven't seen some of them he
makes I think the very first giant thing
he made was the Adirondack chair I think
that was the first one I saw I don't
know if it was the very first yeah he
took a break from doing massive stuff
and then he went on like a massive stuff
like joyriding he made like a gigantic
utility knife that's like two feet long
with a giant blade giant Nutcracker
that's as tall as he is maybe taller
yeah and then like a hand plane a hand
plane that like has a blade that's like
a foot wide or something like that yeah
a giant screwdriver
yeah giant screwdriver yeah it's all
made out of resin yeah which is insane
yeah they're they're jackman sized
builds yeah so so that's important to
know for this upcoming interview but
before like don't like tease it too much
let's just jump right into it how much
sawdust have you actually eaten were
there any things have there been any
because you put a lot of like secret
things secret things in your net secret
things they're like subtle easter eggs
really people have to be paying
attention and I'm sure that adds a lot
of work like how much extra time goes
into that are you just gonna come up
with them on the fly yeah it usually
happens on the spot it's not planned
most of the time sometimes I'll just
like wake up in the middle of night and
think of a funny idea and write it down
like I'll incorporate that in a project
eventually and there are you go to sleep
afterwards because
sometimes can but a lot of it just pops
up on the spot it's just I don't know
it's natural yeah yeah so has there been
any like so subtle thing that no one's
noticed it probably oh yeah
no and that's the funniest thing too is
when they don't pick it up because I
watch them in the comments yeah don't
pick up on this stuff yeah but you know
yeah people gotta look for that so I'm
at this point yeah so they're looking
for stuff to jump in and I mean there's
the obvious like power you know magic
that happens yet like touching you know
you did the jackman touch and it turns
into perfectly plain wood and stuff but
are you fun to hide something where I'm
sorry it would be fun to hide something
where like people have to watch multiple
videos to get it like there's a message
or something about doing that maybe you
should watch it's like an Instagram
someone liked actually like a picture of
like a map with all the videos in the
stream it's like imagine Always Sunny in
the Nutcracker that I made the giant
Nutcracker yeah and in the first photo
that I took the Nutcracker model was
hiding in the background well the photos
progressed it got more and more obvious
until finally a few people picked up on
it at the end of the project I published
a or whatever multiple pictures on the
Instagram I was like this is I circled
it I was like he's been hiding all these
photos this whole time even before
people knew that it was a nutcracker
yeah
oh wow I was in the background you had
it just look like segmented rings I
don't think I was making a bowl or
something yeah but it was out yeah so
you can see like the red and green
Nutcracker if you're looking for does
anything of Joker for some reason I
don't know the plan has been there all
along
yeah so I think that like one of the
thing is it ties together a lot of the
things that you do is like going that
extra step with sponsors you like
integrate their caught their their
products even more you you know go the
next step with your products
in terms of the editing the stop-motion
and all of that and also like the
project itself like you're not just
gonna make Nutcracker it's gonna be
giant six and a half feet tall did you
kind of just like find your way there
gradually naturally or has that been
like the thing that you've been pursuing
I don't know I guess it's been a slow
progression but I started this when I
was like a teenager I went to a trade
high school and learned a lot of what I
know from that Wow so I started early so
I had that you know what that advantage
ahead of me yeah and it just kind of
built from there so I've gotten to the
point where I'm pretty good at
woodworking like when I see something I
know how to make it so kind of naturally
has just progressed into pushing it to
the next level yeah because I'm Jewish
all the normal things right now let's do
the crazy i bill 20 of boxes and holes
and stuff yeah yeah that's interesting
yeah but it's just progressed from that
and like pushing it to the limit so you
know anybody can turn a segmented Bowl
but like what's the infinite extent of
that how far can you push it the
technique is all the same yeah yeah all
the fennel mint all the fundamentals are
exactly to say yeah what the end goal is
like something you haven't seen before
we're just wanted to do it was crazy to
see on Twitter we saw that you responded
to a rhett and Link post yeah about the
cutting board I didn't know about that
origin story on the show had you noticed
it I think I've seen it and though in
the future but didn't know it was your
creation no that's so crazy so I was
like who's had the first launch that you
had that was yeah that was a big spike
that was one of my first I don't know
dozen videos Bravo well so it was really
early on and I was I just love what
they're doing like they always have a
cool spin yeah on how they're building
their business and like they started by
making like comedy like parody TV
commercials and they push things to the
next level they do yeah yeah in every
genre so yeah like I just heard they're
coming out with like a novel that they
wrote like that's the latest thing but
they have a podcast they make these
videos they just started like their own
patreon thing but like their own version
of patreon yeah so it's better like Wood
Whisperer guild but for comedy right ah
yeah right but just for their Channel
yeah so don't off the backbone of what
patreon is yeah but with their own
branding on top of it oh they're using
the
John like code right and everything but
if their own with their own coding of
everything yeah what somebody else has
done that I can't remember who it was
but they patreon like acquired another
company that is like the backbone of
patreon or Wow and now they've taken it
in and kind of you know added that to
their company but they're always you
know at the start of things and pushing
yeah
developing what's new yeah finding that
didn't they acquire isn't a company
called kit they acquired somebody
recently maybe I don't know they did
acquire them that's different though
yeah they're all over the place you
can't keep up with them all right well
yeah so the cutting board popped up on
on Twitter because they broke it they
were like chopping a chicken's head off
like a black chicken I have no idea what
the story behind that but they ended up
cracking the board right down the middle
oh man and that was about three years
ago that I built it the chef though said
he's been abusing and he's been seeing
that crack growing yet by bit I now say
like destroy it every time a few months
ago cuz I watch whenever they bring the
cutting board on it's like hey that's it
and like it's it's really nice to see it
it's like a child of yours and they
destroyed it he's nothing anybody else
but I just know when I see this like hey
I made that four years ago yeah
noticed a small crack in the front of it
I was about to send him a new one I was
like actually just surprise him with a
new cutting board oh yeah send me the
old one back and I'll keep that just as
like a momento yeah with all the scars
and pages and sell it on eBay for a
million dollars and retire so do one get
the destroyed one and then you can like
like domino it back together with like
some glowing epoxy down the center or
something like that so I was talking
with Josh I think the mythical chef Josh
they call him yeah I was chatting with
him on his Twitter DMS yeah and we're
working something out stay tuned yeah
but they've already disclosed the old
one because I know to me and they said
we
[Music]
well let's say politely told you today
to got rid of it yes so the wording that
they said that they recycled it so I was
like so you had a bonfire how do you
recycle it they gave it a Viking funeral
probably yeah it's it's been disposed of
yeah it was a nicer way of saying that I
guess so with all of the effort you put
into each video is there one video that
like you like put all this effort into
and you thought it was gonna be like the
hero video and then like no one just no
one found it like it didn't get get out
as wide as he thought I don't know
there's a lot of those oh yeah cuz like
every video is like oh this could be a
million views just cuz it's crazy and it
seems yeah an awesome build and
sometimes they pop out sometimes they
don't
yeah the nutcrackers at like eighty
thousand views which is pretty good yeah
I got solid but I was expecting more
just because of how big and I figure
this I mean it's a big enough ik thing
yeah it was it was a big yeah I'm taking
it to build that there's a lot of hours
in your edits I imagine it takes you a
pretty decent amount of time I know
sometimes we'll talk to people and
they're like yeah I'm not gonna add some
two hours and I'm like yeah but I mean
yeah yeah I guess it's hard I mean if
anyone knew what was gonna happen the
future and could like understand why the
internet loves some things and not
others right we would we would you know
we would be taking off like crazy but
it's it's so hard to predict things
especially with the viral ish type
content you know you never know what's
gonna like changing in a certain way
yeah that's true and I think like it's
not even so much like what the internet
will like I mean it's about what the
certain portion of people that happens
to see your video in the first 24 hours
like what they like and then they kind
of determine chance yeah it like more
people saw it they might love it but
they just don't know
in front of them yeah yeah oh no sorry
what were using I was just gonna say
like that's the chance that we have to
take with every video yeah but you never
know what's gonna happen when you put it
out but the good thing about us is the
risk reward is pretty good yeah you have
to risk there the risk of your time
invested yeah in that project what
probably has got you too much money yeah
so it's not a huge risk for a potential
you know you could get a million views
on it and have huge growth in your
channel or it could flop and you get 20
30 thousand views and that's fine yeah
and you move on to the next project
but I mean like the thing is it's like
gambling but even losing is winning
right yeah yeah yeah it's like the
outside is like oh yeah potential huge
positive yeah exactly and that's why
it's so addictive to put out videos yeah
yeah I'm guessing I'm assuming that you
might have a similar sentiment the
hardest thing for us about this is not
getting to be able to do all the videos
we want to do yeah
is that about the same time is a
limitation time is such a particular
constraint right there you know yeah but
the time is like the biggest project a
smallest shot proportion I can think of
of people projects or some of the
biggest I mean there are other people
with small shops too like our shop is
not huge or anything
I think Bob's might have been the
biggest channel with a smaller shop I
mean the original shop yeah yeah it was
like a closet a large closet my garage
so that I can take that title whatever
the ratio shop size is subscribers you
crawl in and you have like the most
ultra wide camera in the corner a little
your little station let's see the whole
shop in one shot yeah okay what you do
building out of acrylic and then you
have all the different angles set up
serial you'll be in there the cameras
outside so you're not tripping over
tripod genius
you do is you get some hamsters that
yeah get some hamsters it's a little
house right next to your workshop for
the hamsters and then do hamster size
projects okay in your tiny place I'll
say hamster power tools you might as
well put them to good use and if you're
building them projects then they should
work so all of a sudden a really really
really tiny brush just like 2020 as soon
as the year starts jackman size flips
build a giant pole barn buzz and then
like yeah your big stickers right now
they're just like get the tiny stickers
you know the little like tiny Jackman
bomb everything everywhere yeah yeah I
used to work with this this old
woodworker like super smart guy and we
had this theory that miter saws are
hamster powered never if you ever like
push down on the trigger and you really
listen to it it takes like I don't know
15 20 seconds for actually to get up to
speed yeah so if you actually listen to
it you can might picture a hamster and
they're just running as fast as poss
we'll have to take ours apart one day
and tell you my theory so I don't do
that okay or so so one thing that I was
curious about it it seems like see went
you did what working really early on and
have you disliked stayed within the
woodworking like is that has that been
your job for most of your life yeah so I
did that at the vocational high school
and that as soon as I graduated I
started doing it on the side just like
side gigs yeah and I would build some
small pieces of furniture and I did some
like deck building some small remodeling
jobs and I went to college and during
summer summer breaks and vacations yeah
I was back home building stuff yeah and
that's how I paid for college Wow I
doing all those side jobs I mean it was
a lot of it 100
a week or something yes I presume it's
nuts but I was able to pay for college
with that Wow
so it was a part-time job a full-time
job over the summer wow really
and then as soon as I graduated I you
know worked in the construction industry
for three years as an estimator uh-huh
and did it on the side at that point -
yeah I had my like first videos of you
look way back in the horrible videos oh
that was the original shop yeah and I
was there for three years just kind of
figuring stuff out and putting a shop
together there yeah and at that point
after three years I took it full-time my
wife trying the Coast Guard we had to
move I had to quit my job so I was like
well let's give this a shot I was
starting to see some traction on YouTube
I was really getting into the video so
what what subscribers were you at when
you kind of went full-time I had no
business going full time I had like
20,000 subscribers or something hey
we're doing ads at 20 you know you can
start monetizing
I feel like at the time cuz what how
many years ago was that oh yeah yeah
early days yeah I feel like that it
might have been this is just me
speculating it seems like it might have
been harder to get sponsors being at a
smaller size then than it was when we
were starting to get sponsors you know a
cup like year and a half because it's
becoming more and more of a known thing
two more big things so like there's more
competition yeah but also it's more
familiar to the brand's yeah content
creation yeah yeah that's that's really
true at the same time yeah well I mean
like it's it's really hard to give it I
feel like I say this all the time but
it's really hard to give advice to
people pursuing this as a career because
one every type of content is different
- everything's changing all the time
right and three I have to say three cuz
yeah well so what what the only exciting
things coming up in the future more big
build big build like a you know crazy
idea that you were gonna do and you had
to cancel it for summaries like it was
too crazy or just too impractical it
didn't work I do have one idea and I'm
not gonna share it because it might
still happen
whoa but it was like a collaboration
with a couple brands that was gonna
happen at Maker Faire potentially uh and
it's a it would be a big undertaking
like a huge time commitment
yeah probably take me a couple months to
build so I'm trying to figure out how to
make that work financially to make sense
like I can commit two weeks to making
300 coasters and make it make sense
barely yeah but this project would be a
big undertaking so it's there's
potential there so if you prefer the
bigger and less frequent projects or
that's what gets me excited yeah so
that's what I ulis things like going
that extra distance yeah yeah there's a
popper tuna tease to work with brands
and make smaller things I've said no
yeah it was more simple stuff yeah it
just doesn't excite me anymore so yeah
do it yeah yes say no yeah and yeah you
you gonna made that choice right yeah
I'm in a really nice position I'm good
lucky to be able to do that yeah and
I've been I've had that mentality since
the beginning though so it's a bad
business move it's very fulfilling for
me but at the same time it's great to
keep your voice and your personality and
everything consistent yeah for your
brand instead of yeah very adamant about
yeah like I've never done a mid-roll ad
on my video just cuz I don't want to do
that yeah for some people if they want
to do it I'm you know you guys do it do
it yeah and that's fine but this on my
channel I just felt like it didn't feel
right yeah like if I put that in my
videos so I've been you know insisted
with brands and working with them like
this is what I want the video to look
like and if you're not okay with that
then you know we'll just move on yeah
it's not gonna be a good relationship
for either of us yeah so if we just
can't make that work and you know
organically integrate it into the
project then yeah I'll find somebody
that wants to do that yeah it's pretty
nice to organically integrate like this
all like very literally the things
you've had recently been building you
build like the hand plane and that's
that's the thing you know it's like yeah
it works out pretty good yeah yeah
that's the whole video the whole build
is an ad yeah doesn't feel like an ad
and it gave to the job in a way really
nice yeah and then you're creating a
win-win-win
yeah you know so the whole I don't know
that'll be probably a 15 20 minute long
video there's a whole 50 20 minute long
video
is Rockler yeah yeah but it's very
organically integrator you don't feel
like you're watching an ad so it's it's
good for the brand it's good for the
viewer it's good for me but it's like it
works out really you would want to do
that anyways you know till you you just
want to build a giant hair plane that's
super exciting who wouldn't want to do
that you have to figure out how to give
value to the brand - yeah yeah so that
it works out at all at the same time the
win-win-win the win win win win win win
win win
speaking of sponsors and winning and all
of that stuff we're brands cons are
still going on out there we don't wanna
keep you for too long yeah there's like
sneaking away into our little corner
yeah but thank you so much for coming
onto the show thank you and now we're
back from outer space probably such a
natural thing to say don't you think
well I think that kind of related to the
talk we had with Paul I think that one
thing that would be fun to talk about
and we've actually gotten a lot of
questions about it is like how we come
up with ideas what's the process behind
it and I think like the most common
question we get around ideas is are you
guys gonna run out are you afraid that
you're gonna run out not a fear we just
have too many ideas the fear is not
getting to the mall or that like you
have a really awesome idea it's not that
we want to be jealous for their ideas
but we can you know it's like it's like
we put a lot of time and thought into
these ideas cuz their ideas and we
thought of them but like you know I
don't know it's like there's only like
one time where someone gets to me first
that's true yeah yeah yeah we have in
first available geode table yeah
that was first yeah we you know and
we've done a lot of original things too
I mean like you know this this this desk
is such a combination of so many
different things you know I think the
thing is like so even using the geo
table or the desk no idea I mean this is
no idea is a really unique sentiment but
no ideas original like the geo table
we've seen people do and if you don't
know that's our table where we took like
a cookie slab and we carved out the
middle and we poured a resin geode into
it we've seen people do resin geodes
before we've seen people make cookie
slab tables before we we've seen people
do part power carving before we just put
those together behind elements yeah and
I think you know that I think some
people put a lot of pressure on
themselves to come up with something 100
percent unique but everything is
combining some form of elements and
putting your twist on it yeah I mean
that yeah that could be said about
anything I mean like you know painting
or painting oh people have used brushes
to put paint on canvas before it's like
paint the canvas with my eyelashes or
your feet no people have done that yeah
I know that from sing Simone yeah what
about your nose too easy that's too easy
that's horrible like it's like blinking
a painting into existence all of your
eyes you gotta suffer for the art for
the art you gotta suffer for original
art you just be real careful and you
just for those of you listening get
anything from that Kalin was blinking
against her microphone did you hear it
yeah subtle tomorrow there okay we're
getting a little off track I think that
okay so going back to our list of ideas
we have multiple lists of ideas we have
a whole Google document full of ideas we
have our air table full of like next
year more urgent ideas how would you say
we come up with ideas because it's kind
of a hard question to answer where do
you go for inspiration we come up with
ideas in three ways and I didn't think
this through before I said three but now
I have to come up with
but like III was thinking them of them
as I raised my hand so I think it is
three okay so one just incidental like
like you see something here who
it's like inspiration just strikes us
right because like a lot of ideas have
happened from just like out of nowhere
in the middle of the night or while
we're walking something just hits us and
we just that that that and I think that
those do come from somewhere it's like
we have in brainstorming in the back of
our head or even thinking about this one
thing that's interesting but that's like
the slow method right wait for it yeah
there's another method where we really
just like sit down and we just
brainstorm yeah you know and I think
that helps when you have some I think
that that method is easier when you have
some sort of pre-order yeah yeah you
have to be restricted to a certain
degree like it has to be out of wood or
it has to be power carved or it has to
be like you know using a CNC I think
that putting some parameters around that
brainstorming really helps and I think
it's okay to set false parameters for
yourself like even that makes it
interesting sometimes even if there are
no parameters to be like okay I have to
do this project you know a lot of people
will do limited tool builds so it's like
I have to do this project with only two
tools yeah what can I do with only two
tools or I have to build something
entirely you know or whatever the
construct might be yeah and I think the
third is targeted research and I think
that's separate from just like alright
let's just do something out of wood and
let's brainstorm go like this is like
will go to se will go to Instagram will
go to chest will like really and and I
think that within that targeted research
you can target something broad or you
can target something really specific I
think those are the three ways we come
up with ideas yeah yeah I think part of
it sometimes this might be like a fourth
way is looking around the house and
seeing what we need in points or things
they're missing yeah like for example we
knew in this office we needed a podcast
us yeah and then once we had that that
was our constraint yeah okay
researching from there how do we make it
interesting yeah and I think that you
know we've talked about this before but
there's so many factors that go into
what idea we pursue yeah I mean I think
that there's there's I think I don't
ELISA number but let's let's go through
the things that are most important one
is it feasible within a reasonable time
frame yeah that's kind of like a really
big factor because if it is if it takes
us too long then we just kind of can't
do it yeah I mean maybe eventually if we
got to a point where we had so much
crazy lead time but we're not there we
do have that one idea that we want to do
really bad but we know it's gonna take
like three weeks yeah yeah it's just the
coolest idea guys I know we do need to
just start doing that one little little
by little but yeah I think so time like
feasibility during a certain for your
time that is that's a big one I think
that another is will it be interesting
it has to have one element of like
interest to it
I mean I wouldn't say it has to have one
element of interest to it I think it
either has to be kind of like useful or
unique or you know have an opportunity
for humor or it just has to have like
one at least one thing that makes it
stand out in some way you know so it's
like you know replacing the faucet you
know like interesting
I'm not sure what no no no so so I think
we can't exclude stuff like that because
we've done stuff like that we even have
a project coming up that is like a
common household kind of fixing up DIY
not like a big makeover so that's why
I'm taking out the qualifier of like it
has to have one interesting thing I
think like you can make anything
interesting if you're interested in
doing it Yas it because we don't need it
to replace any of our faucets those
projects we have coming up
those project you guys will be seeing it
soon it's it's one that like we actually
really need we really need we can tell a
story around us maybe not the most
exciting thing yeah but because we
really need it and we've been putting
off her so but I think that is an
exciting thing that is like the thing
that makes it next-level cause like we
can tell a story around that yeah but
you can you can apply that to anything
you know what I mean like it it doesn't
have to be inherently interesting like
if you saw it on paper yeah that makes
sense yeah I think like you just have to
be able to to get excited about it
yourself okay you can get it excited
about yourself you could make it
interesting so I think I think that's a
better qualifier we have to be excited
about it yeah because if we're not
excited about it it's not gonna be a
good video but we can get excited about
all sorts of things whether we need it
whether it's something used in a new way
whether it's like something that's gonna
be funny yeah you know I'm sorry I think
that that's it it's not that the project
has to have something unique going for
us is that we have to be excited about
it for some reason yeah and there's a
lot of reasons why we could be excited
about it yeah okay so time excitement
yeah what else so this one isn't really
that much of an issue but it does affect
like the timing of things more than like
what project we tackle it's more about
when we get to tackle it but sponsors
mmm yeah almost all of our videos are
sponsored it's you know sponsors make up
60% of our income so we kind of have to
like that's why we were able to do this
full-time so early on yeah exactly yeah
if we didn't have as many awesome
sponsors as we do we might still be you
know working our day jobs right yeah and
only making a few videos a month no hey
that would be impressive every were able
to keep that up for this one but but
yeah so a lot of times the timing of
stuff will be affected by sponsors so
there are some sponsors that they don't
give a crap about what video you put
their ad with which is so great which is
super awesome
the downside is usually it you know
comes off as more of an ad read rather
than a natural integration yeah you know
cuz it's like Squarespace is an example
it's not related to the project at all
which is great they don't care what we
put it with but because it's not related
if you
like in a breed but then other other
brands you know like glows for example
it's very closely tied to what we do
like project wise and so but it's
interesting because like you know you're
trying to create this you've got to say
win win win in the interview win win win
[Laughter]
mission to proceed but it's like you
know if if you if you can find a project
that you're really excited about and it
fits well with a brand and it's
something that your audience might love
that is like a perfect win-win-win
situation but at the same time if you're
restricting yourself from tackling
things because you don't have a sponsor
and having a sponsor that doesn't fit as
well allows you to do something that you
enjoy and your audience will enjoy I
think it's still a win even though it's
not as closely tied okay yeah I mean
especially now nowadays it seems like
most people are they accept sponsored ad
spots yeah videos you know there's so
many more people doing YouTube full-time
and it's just kind of like how it is
yeah you know so it's like our Bob Ross
video I'm not sure if we could have
gotten any sponsor naturally to tie in
like yeah no one was gonna like like no
paint I mean we tried reaching out to
like art company yeah we driving molten
yes multiple multiple and we got like
partway down the discussion route with
them and things just fizzled out just
because maybe the budgets not there I
mean it's hard to convert a company
that's never done it before yeah we've
done it some times but we've tried a lot
of companies just because we wanted to
work with them and you know it just
fizzled out but yeah so it's great to
have you know one of those non specific
sponsors like non project specific
sponsors to be able to allow you to do
something like a Bob Ross painting
another thing that's that's hit me
recently is the performance of your
videos isn't at all proportional to the
amount of time you put into them oh yeah
no it's so true and sometimes yeah
put a lot of thought and time into the
setup or the idea or whatever you know
if you have a really good idea sometimes
that's where a lot of the value is but
there is no real correlation between
amount of time put into the project and
amount of views it gets ya know it's
it's it's super true for example like
our spin art video is sitting at half a
million views half a million I just saw
that yeah you know we put some time into
the idea some time into the setup but it
was one of our quicker videos to film an
to edit and to think of the idea and
some of our other videos we put much a
much higher amount of time into the
project and even into the Edit and yeah
it's like you know didn't perform as
crazy as that yeah so it's like the idea
is so important in terms of like you
know putting a lot of time into that
before we even start filming and we do
we put a lot but also I mean just like
we are saying it's not necessarily
proportional yeah oh and time like
thought into the idea I'm saying like
it's really important to put a lot of
time and thought into your idea before
you even start because if it's a really
good idea then you can maybe combine
like a shorter project and really like
and then you get a really good video out
of it putting more time spending more
time on the idea upfront
yeah which might like save you putting
time into something that maybe was like
90% or 80% there but it could be a
hundred percent they're really really
good idea a really good example of this
concept it's like sometimes the words in
my head don't come out right and I need
to talk until they make sense the spin
art is actually a perfect example of
that because oh yeah we had we thought a
lot about this and we were like let's do
spin art but then like what do we spin
do we spend a canvas do we spend
something this is pre-made and ready to
go so that it's more accessible and then
I thought I actually thought like my
first thought that came into my head is
like oh I'll just like 3d print some
parts and
spin it up I have a motor and I can do a
custom mount to it I even 3d modeled it
and I was getting ready to print and
then Caitlyn and I discussed it more and
we're like oh let's just modify a fan
like the the people on Pinterest do or
on Instagram does melee art and you know
it's like we worked through all of these
iterations and it came up with something
that was really simple and accessible
and I think that's one of the reasons
why this took off so much because we
really thought about how to shape the
idea yeah this I don't just go with your
first instinct sorry my nose itches I
need Chloe nose so I think like in the
end and you know I coming up with ideas
has never been something that's too much
of a struggle for us you know we've
always been in like creative positions
at work where you just got to come up
with stuff and I I think the concept of
coming up with ideas can be really
intimidating you're not in practice of
it yeah but I think if you don't put it
on so much of a pedestal I guess and you
just kind of start like a lot of times
the projects will just start like like
yeah we will just list the dumbest stuff
and have a rule that like you can't you
can't start shooting down ideas until
we're done with this round of just
listening every dumb thing yeah I think
if you allow yourself to do that you
might be surprised with what you come up
with and also you know don't be afraid
to look at other places for inspiration
cuz just cuz someone's done it doesn't
mean you can't put your own unique twist
on it yeah you know I think there's just
there's a lot of things that make it
intimidating but if you take away some
of those factors like oh it can't be a
dumb idea oh it has to be 100% original
if you take those away I think you can
come up with some really cool stuff you
just need to get past that mental block
yeah and attacked us cuz we we bring
some ideas like pretty much every day
almost yeah I like some of our ideas for
earlier videos I was like wow kind of a
dumb idea no but like it does take
practice to get to ones where you're
like oh that I still like that idea I
still think that was a cool yeah I'm
glad we did that you know so good
thoughts good message good good
thanks Philip I think that signals it's
time for game time all right so today
we're gonna be playing would you rather
yeah no you know so funny talking about
coming up with ideas we were coming up
with ideas for would you rather just
right now Oh such good segue yeah I was
right before and like one of my ways to
come up with ideas for what you're
rather is just think of like areas for
improvement or pain points and think of
either awesome or funny solutions to
those and for me yeah I went on reddit
to browse ideas and get information oh
yeah two different ways to basically
going on Pinterest to get ideas I
restricted my ideas to like a concept
that I could yeah
pain points okay okay
feeling would you rather have a magic
cup that is always full of perfect
temperature T or perfect temperature
coffee tea tea yeah there's like access
tea all the time well because I enjoy
both well I mean I guess I enjoy cold
coffee and hot coffee like yes caffeine
and hot but also iced tea and hot tea
but I feel like coffee I can only drink
so much before I get like the jitters oh
yeah I am doing that all day so you can
only have one to you this isn't part of
the question because this is like kind
of more open-ended but if you if you
could only have one tea in there in your
magic pot of tea what to you would it be
I know it's kind of like on the spot
like cuz like you yeah like you know
your favorite tea is the one with the
milk in it right that's too much this
isn't this doesn't mean I can't have
other - yeah so the one that I would
have in the perfect cup would be my chai
tea lattes Oh
iced tea it's easier to keep cold things
cold gonna Yeti than it is to keep hot
things hot at least in my cup yeah um
and I feel like it's it's if you have
tea without milk in it it's less gross
to take a sip and you're like oh it's
kind
with milk it's priority Rome's probably
a convenient thing because like like for
me I like the chai tea but I can only
have so much that's it
good answer good answer alright what's
your question for me
would you rather visit the real Jurassic
Park or the real Willy Wonka's chocolate
factory real Jurassic Park yeah because
like freaking dinosaurs man yeah so cool
and Willy Wonka Chocolate Factory
okay I'd have some cool thing that's
going forward and stuff but it's still
just like a crazy industrial factory you
know that's like dinosaurs both you know
and like one thought I had is that okay
you know of course there's there's the
documented Jurassic Park disasters yes
each movie is made about but those seem
to be pretty few and far between yeah
you know like it's like really won't
collect kids in the song a factory once
and they all were horribly yes four out
of five we're terribly injured or
disfigured and you don't even know how
many in bloom pose yeah I lost daily
yeah daily yes Charlie and the Chocolate
Factory a really brutal movie for kids
intense know which which Jurassic Park
iteration would you rather go to go to
like like Jurassic Park one Jurassic
Park to was when the dinosaur came back
on land right you know that would really
wasn't the attraction well the more
modern one I'd say the more modern one
that was pretty cool so the modern one
was cool because there's like the bubble
there yeah the bubble unlike the rolling
ball and stuff yeah that's cool I don't
know though I I kind of want the Jeep
kind of we're on Rails and then you're
just like going through like fenced
attractions and stuff see and when one
you're like on a Jeep on Rails but free
roaming and
that little hamster ball even though
like you know went bad poop went sour
it's not worse but I guess like if
things go down and you're in the Jeep
one you can still drive the Jeep
can you yeah they did they drove the
jeeps okay yeah I don't think they were
on Rails they weren't unreal maybe for
some parts I thought but they're on
Rails but some parts were mules but they
also drove the Jeep remember they're
driving away from the t-rex oh yeah you
know yeah um so I feel like you can
still get away with those bubbles if
stuff goes down and you're trapped in a
bubble like you're just trapped in a
bubble yeah I think I'd still go for the
bubble live dangerously and roam free
with the dinosaurs all right my question
for you would you rather have to cook
every meal for yourself but all the
ingredients are free or you have to go
out forever but all costs are fully
covered
because there's a time commitment there
to you know it's like you you got to
commit fully 100% either way yeah I I
think out cook yeah because like if all
the ingredients are free I could still
save some time by getting like things
that are pre-washed pre-cut like things
that save me some time you know you can
buy like a pre-chopped container of
onions yeah you know instead of and I
can buy chopped onion yeah I don't cuz
they're more expensive that's weird oh
yeah it's like a teepee I mean it's it's
I think they chopped them there I don't
know if all the grocery stores do it but
I think they like chop them thing about
same with like celery and okay cool um
because like there still is a time
commitment to going out because you have
to drive there you have to wait for food
to be served you have to I mean I guess
if you're like going somewhere quick you
don't really have to wait to get your
bill yeah any place quick that's nasty I
mean it's not nasty but like you get
pretty burnt out pretty bad yeah yeah
you do it a few times
oh hi baby you want to join us
supervisor has entered so uh yeah I
think I would still take cooking and
just try to use the advantage of free
ingredients
you save time yeah yeah good answer
I think I think I'll do the same even
though it's like it's such a hard
decision to never eat out ever again
like everything you're giving up but I
feel like you're giving up more or never
cooking yeah but like think about
traveling to you know when you go travel
you'd have to like go to the like you're
you're on vacation you have to go buy
groceries to cook and everything both
suck but like this is more of a curse
thing which is less bad I think I would
say cook everything - yeah yeah because
like there's so many good things that we
cook to it like giving up all of the
things that only are available in our
house yeah dogs suck too and I feel like
you'd end up being less healthy and you
would end up like I feel like when we go
through time periods where we have to
eat out more because we're more busier
or traveling too much we get more food
to doubt we do we do and if we've cooked
a bunch yeah you know I agree okay would
you rather meet Adam Savage more you
never have to trim trim your beard or
hair again it's just always the perfect
length that you want it to be you can
you ask question again okay so these the
two choices would you rather get to meet
Adam Savage yep or you never have to
trim your hair or beard again they're
just always magically whatever length
you want them to be okay I would rather
go with the full control over my facial
hair use that feature to get wildly
popular and then meet Adam Savage
because in your question you said would
you rather meet Adam Savage that's like
a guarantee and you didn't say like and
if you choose the other you never get to
meet him you know yeah use my famous
like world famous so it's like I'll go
on stage and I'll go boom big facial
hair know what long flowing hair and
it'd be so magical and everyone would
want to see it in real life including
Adam yeah there you go
the picture of you like gloriously
puffing your beard to its full potential
good good good attempts to challenge me
though alright
would you rather always have to drive
uncomfortably faster than the speed
limit or uncomfortably slow I couldn't
choose like a specific mile per hour cuz
it depends on like that yeah zone you're
in but like let's say you're like it's
30 you have to go 20 or like 45 and then
when it's like 65 you then have to go 50
or like 85 or something like that
I'd probably go slower you probably go
slower yeah even though like it would be
annoying and both are unsafe but I
figure I'm less likely to get pulled
over if I'm going slower it sounds like
I just over the edge of what's
acceptable yeah seven over I'm like
thing like 15 yeah I feel like fifteen
over or like 10 to 15 nothing extremely
dangerous but just like wrong
uncomfortable so you're it is
uncomfortable
I don't like Lee to get in trouble if
I'm going 15 over yeah
rather than an uncomfortable so annoying
it would be super annoying
yeah but you're right I think I'd do the
same even though they'd suck yeah I did
do a few cursed ones and this like would
you rather have this cursor this curse
okay here's one would you rather have a
completely automated home like
everything is smart or a self-driving
car like truly self driver truly
self-driving and and what would the what
would the fully automated home give me I
mean you could basically voice control
it's it's within like what is possible
now okay then it's totally self-driving
car feels like like fully self-driving
but you can do a lot now like like
you're all your lights your
Acey you're like you can turn on other
thing no it's like cuz like fully like
to the like level it's available today
equip in your house with this feature is
cheaper and easier than getting a fully
self-driving car okay are you saying
like fully self driving or just like
some autopilot capabilities fully so
what if the house is completely
automated self-driving cars like we
could just like go travel wherever and
like work in the car as we travel and
like that'd be so nice we could travel
more cuz that's something that I'd like
to do yeah and I'm just driving is so
onerous is that the Wrightwood owner
annoying annoying okay on the house okay
yeah give me more I don't really know
[Music]
have a robotic house that can cook and
prep meals then house okay yeah so it's
like we basically train the house to
like know our recipes and we can say hey
house make up some chicken fried rice or
like some pasta cheesy sauce yes etc
then oh yeah oh yeah like what why what
would okay so what which would you
rather choose I probably have the same
answers okay so what what would the
house need to be able to do to make it
worth giving up a fully self-driving car
it'd have to be like any big pain point
the main the main like reason against
the self-driving cars we don't have the
need to drive that much yeah but I think
that if we had a fully self-driving car
we would go on trips more I think we'd
go on like short trips more like we'd go
visit my parents more you know would
build my parents more little things like
that but I don't think we would
necessarily go on long trips more
because the the travel itself like doing
it in a car versus a plane still adds a
lot more time being away on the trip is
still time so it would still be hard to
take I think it really only makes sense
for like short like fewer trips
what if the self-driving car
had like a really nice table in it
really nice chairs and so that we could
like work on our laptops wall while on
the drive you know so you could get like
editing done while we're driving right
yes we could be recording this podcast
right now in our self-driving car
slash conference room you know now it's
just kind of like a house on wheels like
like like this is like a car and then
there's a table in front of us with two
computers and mice and keyboard and
we're strapped into like comfy seats and
we're just like the car just drives you
know what I mean and if needed like we
can like a little steering wheel can pop
out from under the table for like that
last little parking spot or whatever you
know what I mean but like you know it's
just like like a table it doesn't need
to be too big you know yeah right that'd
be pretty cool yeah so what what
features what a house need to like take
it up a level it clean itself it would
need to cook cuz like cleaning only it
needs to happen every now and then I
think that cooking would be like the
killer feature cooking would be pretty
cool yeah but cleaning cleaning is
really annoying okay so this is kind of
like and I don't get to politically to
political or anything but it's just kind
of a curious thought to have would you
rather be responsible for making the
internet free to everyone or food free
to everyone and I know that food is like
kind of the tempting choice you know
because that helped out so many people
and don't worry about the logistics or
the cost like the whole like world would
come together and like have like a
slight fee for everyone question is a
question more like which of those would
you want to be responsible for but but
but here's the thing
yeah with responsibility are you asking
like which one would I rather have the
credit for doing yes or which would I
rather have the tasks of doing credit
okay cuz like the tasks would be both of
them would be like huge and onerous and
stuff but like and like there'd be a lot
of like like if I could if you if you
had to buy
in front of you and the world was
watching okay and you could make one or
the other happen cuz like I thought
about and I was like food was my initial
thought right because everyone needs
food and not everyone has food and
that's a big problem but Internet has
the capability to make people like and
I'm assuming like devices are accessible
and everything everyone has access to
assuming when you push the internet but
everyone also has a device devices and
stuff like that yeah like and power and
everything so they're like there'd be
some like side benefits to computers
going to everyone to the power and stuff
do for the food button yeah is it
something like when I push that button
like those people and families have food
forever forever yeah everyone has food
forever everyone like the entire world
at once joins a global community and
people can like have access to jobs they
never had before all the kennedys food I
mean totally see why the internet
tempting but food is more basic like
means of survival and I think if people
had those basic needs covered they would
have more availability in their life to
like pursue things that you know like
other things like getting internet yeah
you know and like pursuing education and
this and that when like I don't have to
worry about food so true yeah so true
yeah I'll do the same it's an
interesting thing to think about yeah
because like the Internet's like the
more like capitalistic type answer and
stuff like and potentially I don't know
I mean if it was everyone if your answer
had been like you push the food button
and everyone gets like one meal oh yeah
because I think that's more important
yeah even if it was like meals for a
year yeah might be more valuable it's
like internet forever versus yeah meals
for any set period of time but it's
meals for forever yeah yeah I agree
okay okay I like having these
discussions with you would you rather
always be 20 minutes early or always be
10 minutes late always be 20 minutes
early
just cuz we don't have to show up to
that many things yeah there's not that
much waste of time and we always have
our phones with
so we can you know keep up with
productive emails your cutoff time right
because I'm kind of the same I'm like
yeah I'd rather be early and just like
do some productive if it was an hour
early or ten minutes late I'd do ten
minutes late yeah I'm not sure what the
like where the turning point it made for
like 45 minutes early am i yeah because
if you're consistently ten minutes late
then everyone who deals with you knows
me too me too yeah especially like like
there's okay this is a little bit nerdy
time there's a like I've been wanting to
get a pocket computer like a full
computer that fits in your pocket for so
long Halen has heard about it so many
times in college
and finally there's there's one coming
out in 2019 I think like and and there's
been a couple iterations of it but
there's finally one where like it's
powerful enough that it's like really
gonna be usable and it's gonna be like
five-inch screen like seven-inch screen
so you can like fit it into your pocket
and it's a full computer and you can
like play like it's powerful enough to
you could do something like video
editing on it you can do Photoshop on it
yeah it's crazy I know I can run Adobe
stuff on it and it can fit in your
pocket so like what if like you're like
if you have to show up early you just
could not have some editing you know
carry a backpack around how did I get on
the computer thing okay what do you
rather have a hammer that's way too big
or way too small forever into the future
forever and ever never it's like when
you need a hammer it's always too big or
always too small really yeah cuz I feel
like there's such like it sounds like
you know that little little hammer that
mini hammer that we have like that's the
only hammer you have when you need to
drive nails in and if you need that that
that mini hammer you have an even
smaller hammer
it's always too small no matter what the
situation that's always too small I
guess I was trying to think like there's
there's gonna be some situations where
like you're using it in a confined space
you know and then if it's too big you
literally can't do it but it was too
small you can do it is just gonna be
annoying you know like if if there's
like I can't think of it a situation
where this would be the case but give
you how a piece of wood and then it goes
down and then it goes up again and then
there's a nail at the bottom of the down
part and you need a hammer you big
you're just gonna be hitting the wood
I think big hammer Kirsten will be a
workout too you know good for your house
[Laughter]
like as like loved like the visual in my
head just like always having a hammer
that's way too big okay I have a I have
a question for you this this but for
some reason I make this made me think of
it would you rather suddenly grow
fifteen inches taller or fifteen inches
shorter fifteen inches so I'd be like
eight foot five eight foot ten or you
would be what six five
oh sorry you'd be eight foot nine if I
had to choose I'd go shorter because
already being this tall is inconvenient
and like fifteen inches would you be
though let's see if I could still live
as a normal human you would be five to
know your math is wrong I'd be like for
know yeah five to six yeah good five to
plus ten inches that's six foot and then
plus five that's 15 you're six five okay
five - yeah that'd be really short but
still be like a normal human size and I
can still use human things you know I'm
gonna be a small man and that's okay if
I was like over 12 inches 12 inches 15
15 EB 600 no you be seven you be um
seven
seven seven seven still I think that
that's too tall I'd hit my head on every
single door I've put in no cars no cars
ever yeah you'd have to go like the
basketball player out and get everything
custom yeah both would suck I kind of
like my height right now yeah all right
what do you rather have the ability to
pause time but during that pause time
you would age an accelerated rate like
two or three times more or you can pause
time but every hour pause you need to
sleep an additional hour I have to
choose one of those they both sound bad
no you know you don't have to use either
power I'd rather have the second you
grab the side or if I pause for an hour
then I have to sleep for an hour you end
up like at a net neutral neutral but
there might be certain times where it's
like you know borrowing time I'm at
crunch time right now I'm gonna borrow
some time no sleep later when I have
time I feel like the other one you pause
time but then you're losing life yes and
then what's the point of pausing time
yeah right you might as well just do
things during your life yeah you know
you'd have to like really seriously need
to be in some crunch time I feel like
the cost of the other one is less the
cost alone is last yeah yeah yeah I
maybe went a little bit too extreme with
that accelerated time yeah well you know
we want a pause time all the time you
know with love more time but I just
wanted to give you an answer but with
with penalties on it yeah yeah all right
and that's my last one I'm out yeah
that's actually I'm gonna have a couple
more but they're lame well here let's
get our things of the week yeah I think
that my thing of the week is in my
pocket because it is for those of you
who can't see this it looks like a
little like mentos case or no little
case it's about the size of a floss and
inside of it are two earbuds this is you
know nothing new it's just like the
Apple earbuds you know except they're
not Apple they're called sound core and
they're made by inker and they are so
freakin great they I use them all the
time to listen to
Cass music and audio books and a huge
advantage of this little case is when
you put them back in the case they
charge and this like using them heavily
could last me three days I can use them
for like eight hours a day or something
like that they're just like then it's
last forever and they're so convenient
so I'm just really impressed about by
these yeah this is your first time
getting ones that are that don't have
any kind of wire attached to them I
don't we used to have we both have like
some bluetooth ones you know but they
hang around your neck on the silver wire
yeah so the only disadvantage of this is
the right one is the primary and the
left is the secondary so you can't just
wear the left alone sometimes you will
just have one in ya and it's always the
right so it's like some some you can
have them independent or separate but
like then like if you like pair them
differently and it's kind of a pain so
it's like this is their solution just
like don't even bother with it but if
you what if you put the left on in your
ear and you just didn't have the right
one in the case how do it would be fine
yeah yeah we just have to have the right
one out out of the case out of the case
to turn it on yes yeah I think for most
people that may not be used the other
thing I really like it they're just so
convenient yeah yeah my thing my thing
of the week and I'm I'm very late to the
game but the new Queer Eye for the
straight guy
Netflix yeah so good so good I just like
end up so freakin emotional last one
does gommi I was like way too emotional
yeah yeah I think we've watched like
four episodes now of season one I think
there might be three oh dang yeah oh
yeah boy and the first the first one I
had seen an episode here or there yeah I
didn't watch a ton of it but this one
I'm like I'm committed now yeah it's so
good and then the the you know coming
from our background after making videos
it's like you know we obviously don't do
anything into the level of TV or movies
or anything like that you know we're
just two people just making film but
fail
it sounds so pretentious I just have to
like say something but we're making
videos but just knowing what goes into
what they produce is so interesting
because like getting those real scenes
and stitching together that narrative
and everything that takes next-level
effort and and you I just get the sense
that it's such a real experience and
everything more than almost any other
show I've seen yeah that that people
seem really genuine which i think is
really cool and the guys have like
actual real talk with them yeah you know
and it's also just impressive that it's
like like at the same time it's like a
makeover show but also a kind of like
life coaching show but also a like home
so it's like normally no just the home
renovation is its own episode you know
and this is that's just a portion of
yeah this little thing yeah it's just
impressive what they fit into an episode
and it's just really enjoyable it's just
like a fun feel good show yeah yeah yeah
already well I think I think that that
brings us to the end of the podcast you
know little words what do I say now
again review great bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]